Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No placing pranks in
new staff's desks and liquefying them in "record
time!"
Starting a new job can be a stressful experience.
Figuring out the office culture, choosing
a coffee cup in the break room, and deciding
which funko pops look best on your desk, it's
a lot to think about!
The last thing a new employee needs is to
sit down at their brand new desk, open a drawer
to grab a pen, and have their flesh melted
from their skull by a bright blast of mysterious
green light.
It's not funny, we're not impressed anymore,
and staff turnover at the Foundation is already
high enough as it is.
No more pranks, it's not a "right of passage"
if they don't survive it, Dr. Bright!!!